MICHAEL SILISKI: So
I'm Michael Siliski,
product management for apps
and games on Google Play.
Along with Ellie
Powers, I'd like
to talk to you a little
bit about building better,
about how to create
great quality user
experiences in your apps.
So look, as you
guys know, quality
is the foundation of a
successful mobile app business.
Users expect quality.
And it's not enough in
today's mobile app world just
to get people to
install your app, right?
You've got to create
features, create
user experiences that get
them coming back again
and again and again.
You've got to get
them to go tell
their friends about your app.
You've got to get them to want
to spend money in your app.
And we know, and we've seen
consistently over the years
that the higher the quality of
user experience in your app,
the more money users spend.
The better your star rating
on the Google Play Store,
the more money you make.
So it's really worth you guys
investing your precious time
and energy in understanding
what users love
about your apps, what issues
they have in your apps,
and going out and proactively
managing user feedback.
And if you do that,
that investment
will pay off for you guys in
the long term on your business
bottom line.
So there's a lot of different
types of app quality, right?
But what we see is, as
we look at the apps that
are most successful
in Google Play,
there are four main
aspects to what
they do in the quality
of their user experience.
First, they solve real
user needs with features
that users love.
Second, they have not
only a beautiful design,
but their apps are easy to
use and are a joy to use.
Third, they're reliable.
They don't crash.
But they're not data hogs.
And they're not
battery hogs, either.
And fourth, they innovate.
They stand out from the crowd
by building on top of the latest
Android futures.
So we think about applying
these across the entire range
of an app lifecycle, from design
to development to distribution.
And to tell you about how
you guys can apply those four
aspects of app quality across
the lifecycle of your app,
I'm going to invite up our
product manager for developers,
the one and only Ellie Powers.
ELLIE POWERS: Thanks, Michael.
Thank you, everybody.
So as Michael
mentioned, we're going
to go through each of these
three different phases
and talk all about how
to improve quality.
So let's get
started with design.
Does anyone remember last
year's talk about materialism?
So this year, if you don't
remember it or you weren't here
we're going to do
a quick refresher.
Then, we're going to see what
developers like you are already
doing with material design.
And we're going to share
a couple of updates
about what's new in the
material design world.
So material design
is a design system
that's about governing
how UI should move, feel,
and adapt to a user's touch.
If you want to
learn more check out
developer.android.com/design.
It's a great first
starting point.
And material design
has four principles.
So the first one is
tangible surfaces.
The whole idea here is
that the way an app works
should be basically the same
as if that app was made out
of real physical objects
in the real world.
The second one is
print-like design.
The content should be bold,
graphic, and very intentional.
You can use the
material design look
and refine it to fit and
reflect your app's brand.
And third, meaningful motion.
You can use motion in your app
to focus the user's attention,
and to give continuity as a
user moves from one screen
to another in your app.
And fourth, adaptive design.
The whole point
here is that you can
create a layout that
will feel familiar,
whether a user accesses your
app on a phone, a tablet, a TV,
Android wear, or even
an Android Auto car.
The user shouldn't have to
relearn the design of your app
every time they move to
a new device category.
So we're going to watch
a little animation now.
And see if you can spot
these four principles
as we go through it.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So over the past
year and a half,
we've seen a huge
amount of creativity
from Android developers
just like you
as they start using
material design
to make their apps more
beautiful and also easier
to use.
And if you're interested,
you can go to this URL here
to check out some of the best
apps using material design
and get inspiration
for your own apps.
So let's talk about
one app in particular
that's had some huge success
coming from material design.
So here's Trello.
They're an app that
allows you to keep
track of your biggest projects.
And they're super-useful when
you're working with a big team
and you found out that
long e-mail threads
and out-of-date spreadsheets
are not working for you.
So Trello used material design
as a big part of an investment
that they made in revamping
their Android app.
And their mobile lead said
that the focus on simplicity
was a big part of this
material design refresh.
And material design
doesn't just look good.
It also brought big
results for Trello.
You can see here that there was
a 10% increase in the number
of sessions per user per
week, 42% more boards created
for each user session,
and 63% more people
added boards in every session.
So we think this happened
because the material design
refresh helped simplify
tasks in the app,
and also improved
feature discoverability.
And users said that
the UI was a lot more
fun and engaging
to use, as well.
So last year, we heard
from developers, hey,
material design looks really
fun and cool and great.
But you know what?
I'm going to need a
lot more resources
to make it easier for me to make
my design work in the material
design.
And we totally heard you.
We totally get that.
So this year, we've introduced
some new resources here
on the left, which I'm
going to go through today.
And we've also expanded
the material design
spec to include a whole bunch
of cool new widgets, layouts,
et cetera, which are
listed on the right.
I highly recommend that you
go check them out online.
So if you haven't been
to design.google.com yet,
you should definitely
check it out.
This is Google's
first website that's
completely dedicated to every
aspect of design at Google.
And you can see everything
that I'm talking
about today on that website.
You can see what's new
in material design,
get detailed guidelines,
and even find sample code.
We wanted to make
designers' lives easier.
And generating icons used
to take a lot of time,
but now we're offering a big
new library of material design
optimized icons.
And this is a great place
to get started for your app.
Another benefit of using
icons from this new library
is that users may already
recognize these icons
from other apps, making
discoverability easier for you.
We also heard from
a lot of developers
that they wanted to
get detailed design
specs on the wide range
of Android devices
that are available.
So this new Devices tool
gives you a lot of information
that you've been
missing, even including
the recommended material design
guidelines for each device.
Now, I think the
biggest request I
heard last year was, wouldn't
it be great if you could just
provide a lot of
reusable libraries
for these material
design components
so that each team
building their app
doesn't have to build
the same stuff again
and again from scratch?
And we totally agree.
We don't want anyone
here to have to build
the same stuff from scratch.
So we've created these
new support libraries.
Easiest way to use them is the
Android Studio STK Manager,
which we'll talk about
a little bit later.
And if you want to get a look at
all of the old and new patterns
available in these
support libraries,
which are backwards-compatible
with older devices,
you can go to
google.com/design/spec.
And this has screenshots, tips,
and a bunch more information.
And if you're looking for a
whole overview and an easy way
to get started, we have
a new course on Udacity.
It's called Android
Design for Developers.
And it'll walk you
through everything
you need to know
about material design
so you're ready to go and write
code effectively and create
beautiful, beautiful
layouts and get the most out
of material design.
OK.
So that was design.
Now, we're going to move on
and talk about development.
So of course, the big news this
year is Android Marshmallow.
It's cute.
It's huggable.
It's sweet.
This latest Android release
also brings big changes
to developers.
And I want to highlight the two
most important changes today.
The first one is the new
runtime permissions model,
and, also, the second one is
some new features that help
save power on users' devices.
So let's talk about permissions.
If you want to use any of the
Android Marshmallow APIs--
that is, API 23-- you'll
need to transition your app
to use this new runtime
permissions model.
And runtime permissions are
great because they give users
more control over their
private information.
We actually heard some
people wanting this last year
at Play [INAUDIBLE].
And they're also
great for developers,
because they can help
improve your apps' install
and update rates, too.
So does everyone
recognize this flow
from the version of
Android that we use today?
So when you're
installing an app,
users have to accept
all the permissions.
What happens on
screen number 2 can be
a little scary for some people.
It's like a big
roadblock, right?
So this is what a
user on Lollipop sees.
And you can see in
the second screen they
have to agree to everything.
And if there's even one
piece of information
here that they aren't
comfortable sharing,
the only thing that they can do
about it is cancel the install
and go find a different app that
doesn't have that permission.
Not ideal.
So with Marshmallow, we
made that scary dialog box
unnecessary so that the user can
just install the app straight
away.
They won't have to
agree to any permissions
when they install the app.
And when they launch the
app for the first time,
they can access
permissions as needed.
And the app will just
show prompts to them
which they can
accept as they need.
So this is what it looks
like when a user runs
the app for the first time.
These are what the
prompts look like.
And then, the user can,
as you would expect,
click Allow or Deny.
And here's an important detail.
The first time the
permission is requested,
the user might click Deny.
Right?
It could happen.
And that could be because
the user doesn't understand,
or maybe they're just on the
run and they didn't really
read the screen.
And the first time
that Deny happens,
it's really not a
big deal for you.
You can just have the app
request that permission
again later.
And the second time that Deny
happens, that dialogue happens,
you'll get that Do Not Ask Again
option that you can see there.
And you have to be a
little bit careful,
because if the user
checks this checkbox,
they won't be prompted again.
And instead, they're
going to need
to go to Settings if
they want to enable
that permission later.
So speaking of settings, this
is really important here.
Any user on Android Marshmallow
can go to the Settings page
to enable or disable
permissions for any app
on a Marshmallow device.
And that includes even
apps that have not
been updated to that new
runtime permissions model.
So if they go to one of
those non-updated apps
and they do disable
a certain permission,
they will see a warning.
But then, after
that, your app may
run in some unexpected ways.
And this can be
confusing to users.
So we highly recommend
that in order
to make sure that your
app runs in a very
predictable and organized
fashion on Marshmallow devices,
that you go and move to the
runtime permissions model
as soon as you can.
And here's another benefit.
It used to be-- has
anyone run into this?
You add a new
permission to your app,
and then the update
rate is just not
moving as smoothly
as it used to.
Well, we've definitely
been aware of that,
too so we've decided that in
the new runtime permissions
models, once again,
the user has to agree
to each permission
individually at runtime.
Those updates will
keep flowing through
without any sort of block.
So now, we're
going to talk about
when you're moving to the
new permissions model,
how should you think
about the user experience?
You're going to be seeing
these prompts for users.
But there's good ways to do it
and not so good ways to do it.
Users are definitely more
likely to agree to permissions
when they understand why those
permissions are being used,
so we're going to walk
through four different ways
that you can
introduce permissions
prompts into your app so that
users' expectations are met.
So the first one, some apps have
a tutorial at the beginning.
And they'll explain the
major functions of the app.
And this can be a great
place to include information
about why important permissions
are going to be requested,
so that then, later
in the tutorial,
when you request those
permissions, the user won't be
surprised, because
they understand
the context of your
app a bit better,
even though they
haven't used it before.
Now, if your app is doing
something so obvious,
like a messaging app asking
for an SMS permission,
it might be OK just
to prompt immediately
on the first run of the app.
But this can be
a dangerous game,
because if you
think it's obvious
and the user doesn't,
now you have a messaging
app that can't send SMSes.
And that's probably not great.
So you have to be very sure that
it's very, very clear to users.
Otherwise, consider
the tutorial.
So that was about asking
when the user first
launches the app.
But in many cases, apps only
need a certain permission
when they're using
particular features.
So now, let's talk about that.
So the first time that a user
uses one of those features that
requires a permission--
like in this case,
requesting the microphone
permission to record a voice
note-- it makes sense to prompt
the user right when they take
that action, and not before.
And so users, for
example, who are not
taking voice notes never
need to see this dialog,
never need the
microphone permission.
But if they are
going to do that,
then you can just
request it right there.
And it's very clear to
the user what's happened.
Now, in other
cases, the user will
need to understand
a little bit more
and get more education about
how a feature will work
before you can prompt them.
So in this case,
here we're giving
a little bit more education
about what the feature can do.
And then, the user can either
say Try It or No, Thanks.
If they decide to try
it, they would then
get a permissions prompt
after they get some background
on what the feature would do.
So even if you think you've done
a great job of explaining why
a particular
permission is needed
and putting it in context, the
user might still click Deny.
Now, if this is
the case, you want
to make it clear to your
user inside your app
why certain parts of the app may
not be functioning correctly,
and then provide a link
to Settings so that they
can enable the permission.
In this case, the app is using
material design snack bar
to do this right at the bottom.
And this is a nice metaphor.
So this can be a
good time, also,
to reconsider whether Android
Intents might be a better way
to go about doing it.
In many cases, you may be
able to use an Intent instead
of a permission.
And that can be much
more user-friendly.
So to summarize,
here all the benefits
of updating your app to use
Android Marshmallow's runtime
permissions flow.
So next, we're going
to talk about some
of my favorite
Marshmallow features.
They help save users'
battery life, which we all
know is really important.
And as a developer,
you want to make sure
that your app works really
well with these new features.
So first, let's talk
about Doze mode.
Let's say you've left
your phone or tablet
sitting in the living room.
It's not plugged in.
You go to sleep.
You come back in the morning.
You want your phone or tablet
to still be live and not
run out of battery.
And that will happen
in Marshmallow,
because Marshmallow detects
that that device has basically
gone idle.
And your device
basically takes a nap.
So when your app
is in Doze mode,
these are the functions
that are restricted.
And other times, it may actually
be that the whole device is
still being used, but
actually just your one app
that's not in use.
And in that case,
each app that's unused
will go into Standby mode.
And that means that that app
will conserve battery life.
These are the
criteria that Android
will use to decide if that
app is not being used.
And when an app is
in standby mode,
these are the sorts of
things that get affected.
So basically, the
most important thing
that you can do
here as a developer
is to run certain commands
using ABD to basically
simulate these
conditions on devices,
and to test and see if your app
still works as it's intended.
If you really need to
deliver certain messages
and get through
with high urgency,
we offer a special GCM
API that allows you
to send high-priority messages.
So definitely give
this one a test.
Next, we're going to talk
about Android Studio.
So is anyone here using
any Studio already?
Yeah, maybe some people.
Cool.
So we're going to take a look
at some recently-launched
features.
There we go.
So we announced Android
Studio back in 2013.
And so this is basically
Google's official IDE.
And if you're still
on Eclipse, please do
note that will be
fully deprecated
by the end of the year.
So this is a good time to
think about moving over.
So here's what's new.
Most apps don't need C++ code.
But certain apps that have high
requirements for CPU, like game
engines, signal processing,
and physics simulations
will need to use it.
And so if your app does have
one of these special needs,
you'll be happy to know that
Android Studio now allows you
to have C++ code and Java code
live happily ever after in one
project.
And users love
apps that are fast,
that are responsive, and
don't waste resources
on their device.
So Android Studio
provides three types
of tools that will help you
get ahead of the curve here.
First, you can visualize
resource use in your app.
Second, you can identify
wasteful data structures.
And then finally, you
can understand the burden
that your app puts
on users' data plans,
and pinpoint where
to reduce usage.
So at the core of
Android strategy
is our unified build system.
We've made a lot of performance
improvements to it lately.
If you like creating
UI in a visual way,
we have some new
tools that allow
you to drag and drop components
and manage your assets more
efficiently.
And then earlier, we mentioned
how Android Studio can really
help you with material design.
This is the best place to use
the design support library.
And you can just
basically drag and drop
cool material design
widgets into your app
using Android Studio.
And they're backwards-compatible
back to Android 2.2.
So in addition to the
Android design library,
we have a bunch
of other libraries
that you can go learn
more about online.
They can be super helpful
to speed up development.
And then finally,
Android Studio also
makes it easier to bring your
apps to new device types.
You can create a new
Android Wear face quickly,
or even simulate an
Android Auto app.
So finally, we're going
to talk about distributing
your apps to users and
building your business.
So Google Play is all
about matching your app
with the right users
who really want it.
And we also provide
some great tools
to help you improve quality.
But I want to start out
with some really good news.
So today, maximum APK
size is 50 megs, right?
So this is 50 megs.
Anyone have an app almost 50
megs, maybe flirting with 50?
49?
So when that happens, if someone
tries to install a larger one,
you get this warning, right?
Has anyone seen that warning?
And you get a
little bit worried,
and maybe you click back.
Or you have to set up APK
expansion files, which
definitely takes some time.
So we have some good news.
To be announced later
today, 100 megabytes.
We're really excited, too.
We've been working on
this for quite a while.
It takes us a good
bit of testing,
because we have to work
with such a range of devices
and operators.
But we wanted all of you
to be the first to know.
We'll have an announcement going
out on our blog later today.
We just want you
to know one thing.
Even though we will
allow APKs up to 100,
users still really do
like the smaller APKs.
So only go over 50 if
you absolutely must.
So now, we're going to
talk a little bit more
about how to use iteration on
Google Play to test new ideas.
So we offer a whole
bunch of special tools,
which Mark touched on earlier,
to help you get early feedback.
And we recommend these
as best practices
to every single developer.
Our best developers, most
successful developers,
use these tools.
And if you aren't
already, you're
definitely missing
on a big opportunity
to have a high-quality app.
So anyone here
using beta testing?
Fantastic.
I love seeing those hands.
This is a really special
feature on Google Play.
And you can distribute your
app to a subset of users.
And you can get feedback
early, rather than releasing it
to everyone and just
crossing your fingers,
saying, please work.
So with beta testing,
users opt in,
and they can't leave reviews.
And it's pretty cool.
You should definitely
try it if you haven't.
And developers have told
us beta testing is great,
but we want more ways to be
able to make it easy for users
to join.
So this year, we
announced two changes.
The first one was open betas.
You can now actually,
if you want, distribute
a link to your open beta.
And users can just click
it, go to a page that
looks just like this, and join.
And that's it.
They can join with
just one click.
And developers have been
able to grow pretty big beta
communities this way.
You still, obviously,
have the option
to create a private,
closed beta.
But you can also now
manage that with one option
being email addresses.
And we've introduced that
option earlier this year.
So let's see why "The
Guardian" tells us that they're
big fans of beta testing.
Over the past six
months, they've
tried basically every single
feature through beta testing
first before rolling it out.
On average, they do three builds
before each production release.
And they've said
that this really
helps them move a lot faster.
It provides a safe
place for them
to try out crazy new stuff
without risking their brand.
And it also helps them
gather a bit of data
so that they can take
it to stakeholders
to make tough decisions.
It used to take them over a
month to launch new features.
Now it's less than
a couple weeks.
So staged rollouts.
This is another way of making
sure that your app doesn't
release any bugs to new users.
You basically just push
out your new version.
And rather than
going to every user,
you go to a certain percentage.
And you can increase that
percentage over time.
And this year at Google I/O, we
announced the Cloud Test Lab.
And we're trialing this with a
small set of developers today.
And if you're interested, you
can go to the Developer Console
to sign up.
And hopefully, we'll add
you to that beta test soon.
So in Google Play, what's
going to happen with the Cloud
Test Lab is that we're going
to send all alpha and beta apps
to be tested on a set of
real physical devices.
And you'll get results
back pretty quickly.
So this is yet another reason
to use alpha and beta if you
aren't already doing that.
And it helps you detect
any major obvious issues.
And we've heard from some
of the developers who
are trying this early version.
The first thing they want
to do after that is they
say, well, that was cool.
But I want to write some
really specific tests
and run it on this particular
one device that's been really
hard for me to track down.
And so we're actually going
to have a way to do that, too.
You'll be able to write
customized testing,
and then run it
through Android Studio
on either virtual
or physical devices,
specifying the exact set of
devices that you want to use.
So this is what we've
been through today.
First, we want you to be
able to build a great app
and a business on Google Play.
And so in the design
phase, material design
can be easier than ever to
use, thanks to a whole bunch
of new resources.
In the development phase,
Android Marshmallow's
brought some serious
changes for developers,
like permissions and Doze mode.
And so Android Studio
and other resources
can help you test that
out and make sure you
have built a high-quality app.
And then, finally
distributing quality apps
is easier than ever,
and because Play
is offering development-centered
tools that help
you iterate and
test your new apps.
Thank you.